how did the two experiences compare like
doing a late night set on Conan versus
Corden they're actually they actually
were very different just in terms of the
setup like Corden and Conan as hosts
were both amazing they were both
incredibly kind to me both Booker's JP
and Ryan were awesome to work with so
like I had nothing but positive
experiences in terms of doing the show
with the intangibles outside of actually
performing what was different about
Conan and Corden is Conan is much more
like the big studio audience that's 30
feet away from you and Corden actually
has floor seats with crowd members two
feet away so I was actually more
comfortable performing on Corden just
because the literal setup of who you
performed to feels much more like a
comedy club there are people three feet
away from you like what happened in a
front row of a comedy club as opposed to
Conan very much feels like this is a
studio audience that you cannot reach
out and touch is there a teleprompter
shows they there's a teleprompter that
they offer you not word-for-word they
offer you to put your setlist on a
teleprompter in case you like blackout
they give you that option the first time
I did Conan I had it up there just
because I was so scared that I was gonna
get out there just completely blank
the second and third late night sets I
didn't I didn't want it because I didn't
want to have anything to take my eye off
of the audience and just like being in
the moment you know cuz I was like once
you know the teleprompter is there even
if you don't need it you kind of look at
it and I didn't want to throw me in the
middle of performance so again that came
from being more comfortable and knowing
I was gonna remember my you know I
wasn't worried about it what about
backstage do you get like cool gifts or
is there food or like yeah back there
Conan they give you I forget what it's
called but it's like a very famous
Chicago popcorn where it's a mix of
cheddar and caramel corn that's like
their stage gift and then there's all
kinds of just food in the greenroom
available Gordon they asked me what I
wanted in the greenroom and I just said
like fruit and vegetables cuz I'm not
trying to have like a turkey leg before
I go out national TV and then and then
there were some cool gift there's a
a whole lot I think it was a sponsor
there's like lotions in a face mask that
I gave to my wife and she was thrilled
with it the water bottle and a mug and
stuff like that but you're obviously not
doing it for the gift serie of course
but I don't I don't even know what I
haven't been backstage of a show like
that yet so I'm just curious of like
what it is yeah I can fly on the wall
yeah it's just a nice green room where
they give you a mirror and a couch and
food but when when we've been in green
rooms that it can literally be like the
closet right back at this restaurant
it's it's a property no it's a dressing
room another thing I would advise to any
stand-ups if you get your first late
night say I made the mistake my first
late night set of having a whole bunch
of friends in the room so like I had my
manager and then I brought like four or
five people to be in there and it ended
up being too much you know because it
was like I was trying to go over my set
I was already nervous and there were
people talking like you don't want to
bring friends back there and be like
everyone shut the up so they were
having a good time and it was just kind
of distracting and now after that when
I've done it I guess served my wife and
then I'll have like my manager or my
agent and maybe one friend because they
all like Clayton came with me the second
Conan just cuz it's good to have a
support system you don't want to sit
there alone but you also want to have a
small group of people who you're
comfortable being like hey guys can we
just kind of like be silent for a minute
so you can have your moment of peace you
know it's like you don't want to be too
overwhelmed before you go out you wanna
be able to concentrate and have your own
space do you get to meet did you meet
Corden or Conan before the Setter after
the set I met Conan the first time I
ever did Conan right before I went out
like I'm standing there at the curtain
it's a commercial break and that's the
most nerve-wracking because they'll tell
you like ok we just went to commercial
you're next and you just kind of stand
behind the curtain you can hear the the
like studio kind of shifting and right
before I went out and before we came
back from commercial break Conan came
and like shook my hand
and met me and that was awesome but it
was also like I was in my zone trying to
get ready to prepare for Conan and then
hear Conan come it was like awesome to
meet him but also probably couldn't have
been worse timing because I just like
didn't want to meet Conan right before
I'm worried about like my opening line
the second time I had already done it so
like he didn't come by the greenroom or
anything but what was cool it just so
happened the second time I did Conan was
the night of their holiday party because
it was like middle of December and he
invited me to come to the holiday party
that night and that night I went and
actually got to hang out with Conan and
he could not have been sweeter and more
complimentary he's just like a really
good guy and then Corden actually came
and hung out in my dressing room for
five or ten minutes before the show and
I didn't even realize what an impact I
would have on me but it actually made me
so much more comfortable like I didn't
meet suit and tie James Corden who was
out in front of studio audience he was
just kind of himself and he was just
having a drink shooting the and it
was just like way more casual and it
made me feel much better about going and
performing on his show so it was both
both of them were incredibly kind to me
so yeah they were great
[Music]
high breath